[Music]
part of our program involves hunter
collected sample kits and we use those
as a way to monitor the health muskoxen
one of the kits we have the simplest
version is what you see back here and it
is collected by hundred subsistence
hunters but also by the guides for the
outfitted sport hunting
and the the sport hunting ones actually
have been one of our most important ones
because they collect samples every year
at the same time the guides take the
hunters out for their hunt they take a
kit a pre labelled kit with some bags in
it and when they get the ant the muskox
they're able to just take that kit out
and start to collect the samples so we
collect a number of samples and we also
collect data from the the guides about
the animal
No
we collect fecal samples which we can
look at in the lab and determine if
there's lungworm out there the amount of
lungworm we also look at other parasites
in the feces we take blood on filter
paper so this is a technique that we've
developed that instead of the hunters
having to collect bottles of blood or
vials of blood that are very difficult
to handle what they do is they just soak
filter paper strips in the blood from
the animal that goes into an envelope
and then when it gets down to our lab we
loop the blood out so we soak it out and
we can run a whole variety of blood
tests so that gives us a lot of
information on the animals from the
perspective of diseases that they've
been exposed to we collect fur from the
back right over the rump and from that
we take the qiviut which is the
undercoat and we measure stress hormones
the body condition was Kimmy okay and
zero back fat so we have a good sample
for hair you take the lower leg bone
left hind leg and from that leg we can
look at the skin and there's some
parasites that are most common in
caribou but it may show up in muskoxen
so we look at the skin for that parasite
we have the hoof the whole foot is on
there so we can look at the hoof and see
if there are any abnormalities and then
we also cut open the bone and measure
the bone marrow and we use that as a
measure of body condition they also will
tell us what other animals were in that
herd so age and sex they'll tell us the
location and there's an opportunity for
them to make any comments about the
animal if they saw anything abnormal if
it was fat if it was skinny and anything
else like that that they think is
important
you